this video is brought to you by adam and
eve go to adamandeve.com and use the
promo code c at checkout to get 50
off one item and free shipping in the us
and canada
let's start the show
[Music]
he's so different and he's so him but
the freedom if you wanted to have a
legend of a comedian
you would talk about a guy who created
the greatest sketch show of
all time then he goes away and the show
went really well
like absurdly well like so well you
gotta go to africa well
i quit chappelle show in spectacular
fashion hey everybody got an
announcement to make
ding ding ding ding ding i quit
he goes away like a mountain man he
vanishes
he does i was gone for a long time
i watched the world go on without me i
mourned the laws of it and after a while
i didn't care and then came back and
immediately
went right to the top no one's ever done
it better than dave he said
in the time where the fire is the
hottest i'm going to
do what nobody else will dave
you're the goat you the goat you know
you're the greatest ladies and gentlemen
the coach mr dave chappelle
[Applause]
anyway
[Music]
this is weird and and less than that
deal
dave chappelle's special 846 reminded us
all what we already knew
chappelle is more than just a comedian
he's a legend and an iconic figure just
one who also tells [ __ ] jokes i don't
care if he
personally kicked candace owens and her
stinky [ __ ]
this performance shows dave's incredible
flexibility as an artist
not only was it filmed in the middle of
a pandemic that has prevented stand-up
comedy for months but in his own words
this is not funny at all
special only has a little bit of humor
in it and the rest contains a powerful
and personal reflection on the black
lives matter protests the performance
reminds you of just how legendary dave
chappelle
is that he can use his artistry in the
most unexpected ways to do stand-up in
the most
unexpected situations and he's always
been this way he did the same thing
after quitting chappelle show
he was doing stand-up in a park yeah in
seattle he'd show up with a [ __ ] box
and just do it plug
a microphone into it and just start
doing stand-up throughout his life
chappelle has made more out of his
career than just telling jokes and in
doing so he's become more than a
comedian he's a legend
the risk-taking the pressure the
comeback the controversy
it all points to an epic narrative that
transcends his own life it's a story of
a man perfecting his artistry
reaffirming his personal agency
and learning to perform his art on his
own terms and it's a story that's
influenced by and adds to the narratives
of
other legendary african-american artists
pretty much every article or video about
dave chappelle focuses on the jokes he
tells and whether they're funny or not
funny and that makes sense
since joke telling is the comedian's job
but i think that sells dave chappelle
short if he's really a legend and a
thought leader shouldn't we go deeper
than that
what if you study dave's life and body
of work as if he were a legendary artist
like charlie parker or kendrick lamar or
even an intellectual like frederick
douglass because i think dave chappelle
deserves to be treated in that way
there's an incredible amount of meaning
and depth packed into his career along
with the [ __ ] jokes this is [ __ ] juice
so let's see what dave chappelle's body
of work looks like when you approach it
as more than just the work of a joke
teller
were you a an iconic figure
i'm a pop culture figure that's much
different
i don't know uh sometimes the iconic
figure began as a pop culture
[Music]
[Applause]
in 2002 dave chappelle co-created
chappelle show with neil brennan which
would go on to become one of the most
successful sketch comedy shows of all
time but in the middle of filming the
third season he abandoned his 50 million
contract and went to south africa for a
few weeks i already made a video about
why dave chappelle
left his show on comedy central i talked
about an analogy he made in his special
the bird revelation in the analogy
chappelle is a prostitute his sex work
is his work on chappelle's show and his
pimps are the hollywood executives who
manipulated him into overworking under
abusive conditions i do spell show
20 hours a day sleep for like half an
hour raise my kids for 10 20 minutes
and not go back to work it wasn't fun at
all it was hard
we'd have to stay awake for 48 hours at
a time just to keep up with the schedule
we were bombed out and depleted we were
lumped up according to the bird
revelation
chappelle left the show because of that
unbearable schedule and to the
psychological abuse executives used to
try to keep him going why the [ __ ] you
think most of us work
from nine to five it's 96 mike killer
[ __ ]
but chappelle has also mentioned other
reasons for quitting he
wondered about its impact on the
audience
that he meant it for he felt disturbed
at how some white audience members
misread his racial humor somebody on set
that was why i
laughed in such a way i know the
difference of people laughing with me
and people laughing at me and was the
first time i'd ever gotten a laugh
that i was uncomfortable with white
people come up to me like man that
sketch you did about them [ __ ] that
was a lot
take it easy you start to realize these
sketches and the wrong hands are
dangerous
really there wasn't one singular reason
for him to leave i wasn't walking away
from money
i was walking away from the perfect
storm of [ __ ] and
unsurprisingly the media didn't
understand the nuance of his decision
with mainstream outlets circulating
crazy
unfounded claims about his disappearance
and they're saying
you know maybe i smoked crack and it was
all innuendo and then
magazine is credible as newsweek i was
very surprised
the media didn't see that his decision
wasn't a meltdown but rather a
calculated personal decision that
defined his identity going forward
whenever i hear like he fled to south
africa i'm like man
i walked out i walked like john wayne
comparing himself to john wayne shows
that chappelle sees his decision as more
significant than just
leaving a job he didn't like like john
wayne disappearing into the wilderness
in the searchers
chappelle exercised complete control
despite his uncertain destiny
name your price in the beginning if it
ever gets more expensive
than the pricey name get out of there
thus africa there's a long tradition of
african-american
icons visiting africa and undergoing a
transformation
everybody should go home to africa i see
all colors of people doing everything
and the voice said do you see any [ __ ]
i say no
and say you know why because there
aren't any
and it hit me like a shot man i started
crying and [ __ ]
on this pilgrimage what i have seen and
experienced has forced me to rearrange
much of my thought patterns previously
held and to toss aside some of my
previous conclusions
tell you hear a lot of black people say
this like when you go to africa
especially your first time you have this
overwhelming feeling like you're home
which is true
i had to feel like man this feels like
home and like in the narratives of other
prominent black figures
chappelle presents his journey to africa
as a profound teachable moment in his
life that protested against the
hostilities of show business and racial
injustice
i feel like i'm going to be some kind of
parable by either what you're supposed
to do or what you're not supposed
i'm going to be something i'm either
going to be a legend or just that tragic
[ __ ] story but i'm going full
throttle i'm going all the way
his choice to go to south africa and the
way he talks about that choice clearly
shows he sees his decision as more
meaningful than just a career move
even now after leaving show business for
10 years he presents his life as a
parable a narrative to learn from and in
doing so he elevates his story into
myth
the baboons always have a secret supply
of water
and they're not going to tell anybody
where it is i watched one of these
nature shows one time
and they were talking about how a
bushman finds water
when it's scarce and they do what's
called a salt trap first he laboriously
drills a hole in a giant ant heap
when he is sure a baboon is watching him
because he knows baboons are incurably
inquisitive
so they put a lump of salt in a hole and
they wait for the baboon
the baboon comes sticks his hand in the
hole grabs the salt
salt makes his hand bigger and he's
trapped he can't get his hand out
if he's smart all he does is let go with
assault
baboon doesn't want to let go of himself
now he lets go when it's too late
then the bush man just comes takes the
baboon and gives him all the salt he
wants
you know when you're a guy that
generates money people have a vested
interest in control
in fact he has such a ball eating salt
that he completely forgets he's under
arrest
and that in a little while he's going to
be a mighty thirsty baboon well you know
what kills more black people than
anything more than police and terrorism
salt [ __ ] regular ass table saw the bad
boy gets thirsty
the bushman lets him out of the cage he
decides the brainwashing has worked
so he sets him free knowing that in his
condition he won't care who follows him
to the secret reservoir
that i wasn't paying attention i felt
really guilty about being asleep at the
wheel the first place a baboon runs two
is water
bushman follows them and they both drink
to them
and in that analogy i felt like the
baboon but i was smart enough to let go
of the salt
if you had the sense to drop the seed he
could free his hand
i want to give the money to someone
that's not exploiting me the machine is
good for us and we good for the machine
and it should be
should be fair man should be fair
uh you know what uh it's been 10 years
since the last time i played los angeles
in 2017 chappelle released his first two
post chappelle show concert films on
netflix deep in the heart of texas and
the age of spin while they don't linger
much on his past controversies with
chappelle show they do acknowledge
they're still on his mind it was a
difficult 10 years
i'm not going to take you through all
the acne i've been through the specials
don't speak much to the dave chappelle
narrative that may be because he shot
the specials without any streaming deal
and netflix bought them later
i literally just took him out of the
club's like they're both well-made and
funny specials and they gave the world a
re-introduction to chappelle and
primarily served to show he's still got
it
and by omitting the controversy of him
quitting chappelle show and leaving show
business for 10 years the specials also
create dramatic attention
everybody still wants to know how all
that affected him he resolves that
tension in his next two specials
equanimity and the bird revelation these
specials clearly seek to address the
demons from his chappelle show days
one clue is their titles the first is
called equanimity which means an
evenness of mind
especially under stress his very first
joke makes it clear that his comedy is
now
in his hands and after this [ __ ]
it's time to make america wait again the
entire opening shows a comedian who
understands his talent and knows how to
resist to the force of others
you know if you black in show business
and do too well it's scary [ __ ] like
you gotta get the [ __ ] out of the casino
while the getting is good while you're
still winning
if equanimity reflects a comedian in
control then the following special shows
how he got there this next special feels
much more intimate and it's my personal
favorite it's called the bird revelation
and that title actually has multiple
meanings the first interpretation
relates to the prostitution analogy at
the end of the special the word bird is
slang for a girl and dave knows that he
even uses the word bird in this way
during a sketch on chappelle show
it's a bird one of those that you just
bring home and we're out
that is correct a verb that you bring
home and wear out the bird revelation
then
is dave having the revelation that while
at chappelle's show he was the bird
getting worn out
that's the [ __ ] campus
manifesto
and that's why i went to south africa
another
interpretation of the title has to do
with the quote at the beginning of the
special i came alive
i could fly this quote was supposedly
said by charlie parker
after he realized a completely new way
to play music charlie parker's nickname
was bird hence the bird revelation this
second meaning also relates to
chappelle's career like charlie parker
chappelle realized he could do his art
form in a completely new way
after years of leaving comedy he has
come back completely differently
now he can make comedy without the
executives who pushed him too far
in short he's free at first it was scary
now i feel like it's liberating like i
feel free like i can just
say what i want to do i want they
already call me crazy the narrative of
the life of dave chappelle is defined by
one word freedom
chappella is no longer bound by the will
of executives and can now work on his
own terms
and there's really no other comedian
with the level of freedom that dave
chappelle has
you know i got the corporate
relationships and the ceo hat and the
the companies so you know i can't
do certain things and then kevin said
[ __ ] it
i quit and then he went on every talk
show in america and apologized for six
weeks
i'm envious and jealous of dave's
ability to go
and be free as a comic in the times
where we desperately need
to be i'm gonna go to africa i'm gonna
find a way to
i'm gonna find a way to be myself i'm an
artist man
you know i don't i don't need a sneaker
deal that's why i don't have a sneaker
deal because if you say something that
people don't like
they'll take your [ __ ] shoes off
chapelle truly does whatever he wants
sometimes it feels like he breaks the
rules just to remind us that he can
i should also tell you that i skip
rehearsal
during the civil rights movement uh the
i can't
i can't read what's on the teleprompter
and i want everyone in america right now
to look at me
look at me smoking indoors
i didn't ask anybody i just did it what
are they gonna do kick me out before i
get the prize
now [ __ ] this is called leverage
everyone embraces
chappelle's ability to resist the polls
of show business especially in an era
where show business has received a huge
amount of completely warranted criticism
but those aren't the only people
chappelle doesn't want controlling him
and i don't care what i find out could
be today tomorrow 15
20 years from now if i find out you're
[ __ ] do
finished that's you
that's what the audience sounds like to
me
[Applause]
the title of his latest special sticks
and stones has a pretty clear meaning
chappelle is reminding us that
criticisms of him aren't going to hurt
him or his comedy and in classic dave
chappelle fashion
he references other black provocateurs
to explain what he's doing first in the
opening quote
tell me something you [ __ ]
can't tell me nothing
to listen to my dna and then
even more explicitly he quotes prince
lyrics that essentially summarize his
entire argument
and this is the bar the whole song
prince say
trying to run from my destruction
you know i didn't even care
as maureen callahan noted he is telling
us that he is willing to not just
destroy but be destroyed if you consider
chappelle's career up to this point his
decision to continue telling destructive
jokes about things he already got
backlash for
should come as no surprise chappelle
isn't just telling jokes he's making a
broader point
just like when he actively resists the
rules of show business he also resists
bowing down to criticism to remind us
that his comedy will
always be his and his alone whether it's
tv executives or his audience
chappelle will fight back against any
attempt to restrict what he says
some people prefer chappelle's older
comedy over his recent work and i
totally get that
his first two specials killing them
softly and for what it's worth are
easily two of the best comedy shows of
all time but i do enjoy how his more
recent work incorporates the narrative
of his life into his performances
and sometimes he also adds his
experience to the work of other
performers
a perfect example is chappelle's
interruption of kendrick lamar's
performance during the grammys in 2018.
i'm dave chappelle and i
just wanted to remind the audience that
the only thing more frightening than
watching a black man be honest in
america
is being an honest black man in america
sorry for the interruption please
continue this theatrical interruption is
full of meaning
speaking specifically to the nature of
black artistry in the united states the
fact that chappelle introduces himself
feels
almost funny since everybody clearly
knows who he is but that introduction
emphasizes that these are not words
coming from just anybody they're coming
from dave chappelle
another honest black man in america his
presence becomes an authoritative
comment
on the obstacles and risks of a black
man performing his art without holding
back
it looks like he's singing and dancing
this brother's taking enormous chances
and in the same way that kendrick lamar
is not just singing and dancing dave
chappelle is not just telling jokes
in 846 dave chappelle heavily criticizes
the conservative commentator candace
owens
she's the worst i can't think of a worse
way to make money
and owens responded that people need to
be able to laugh at themselves
so she's okay with chappelle talking
about her that way in the end she
probably would have made the criticism
worse if she fought back
there's really no good way to respond to
a comedian acting freely and truthfully
because if you accept that comedians can
say anything then you have to accept
that criticism when it's directed at you
even if it's brutal but if you disagree
with what a comedian says then you can
be criticized for taking them too
seriously and nobody plays both of these
sides more than dave chappelle sometimes
he's just telling jokes that don't mean
anything
and sometimes he's telling hard truths
that mean a lot and he's also doing
everything in between
his latest special 846 and his
performance at the grammys confirm that
he's not just a comedian but also not
just a thought leader
he's both and full of contradictions
like do people care what he has to say
or not
i know nobody gives a [ __ ] what i think
anyway the only reason people want to
hear from people like me
is because you trust me is he telling it
like it is or is he just messing around
i was right once remember that i didn't
come here to be right
give me the [ __ ] around is he a thought
leader or is he just telling jokes
i pride myself on saying real [ __ ]
that people don't even notice i'm saying
uh
and and then sometimes i just tell jokes
that's the beauty of it
there's even something kind of strange
about this video taking dave chappelle
very seriously despite the fact that
some of his comedy is just plain silly
there's not enough stove top stuffing
for everybody so i kicked her in the
[ __ ] but that
is the beauty of dave chappelle he lives
in this limbo between jokes and
sincerity
and he can effortlessly move between
them if he's really a legend then his
work deserves to be treated like art but
if he's also a hilarious comedian then
his work doesn't need to be treated like
art at all you can just laugh
at it his comedy is simultaneously a
joke and more than just a joke
serious and not serious offensive and
not offensive
my favorite book of all time the
narrative of the life of frederick
douglass dave chappelle has an intimate
connection with the great abolitionist
frederick douglass to my knowledge
the first black person that was
officially invited to the white house
was frederick douglass i talked about
how few black people were invited to the
white house how frederick douglass was
the first
and that it didn't happen again until
roosevelt
but that was wrong it happened one other
time before that
that delegation was led by that amy
bishop
william david chappelle
it's where i get my name it was my great
grandfather
who was a slave when he was born and not
only does chappelle's lineage have
similarities with douglas but they also
both create narratives out of their life
stories
the exact phrasing of the title of
douglas's memoir is crucial
it's not titled the life of frederick
douglass but rather the narrative of the
life of frederick douglass his first
memoir has a lot of thematic
similarities with other slave narratives
the story functions not just
as a recounting of frederick douglass's
life but also a story that fits into the
greater narrative of overcoming slavery
in the american south according to
historian james olney
these narratives have three key elements
literacy identity and freedom
slaves learn to read and write in
difficult situations invent a new social
identity for themselves and live their
lives as free men
and abolitionists olney's most
interesting claim is that these
narrative elements actually occur
past slavery and into african american
literature in the jim crow era with
stories like black boy and the
autobiography of malcolm x addressing
similar ideas of learning to educate
oneself reinventing one's own identity
and advocating for freedom from
oppression
dave chappelle embraces his relationship
with frederick douglass and in many ways
chappelle's story has parallels with
that traditional
afro-american narrative his literature
is his artistry as a comic his identity
is the independence he declared by going
to africa
and his freedom is advocating to say
what he wants on stage
he knows who he is right he's not
compromising and no one can tell him
any different i understand what i am i
really do
more than anybody when's we gonna be
free
that is a good question my man
how about nowish
dave chappelle tells his story by
recontextualizing it in the stories of
other african-american figures whether
it's through a pimp in the 40s
frederick douglass visiting the white
house or kendrick lamar he finds a
commonality in these stories and that
commonality elevates his story
and his career to that of a legend the
vast majority of articles or videos
about dave chappelle
analyze his jokes but i think that sells
his career short
obviously his comedy is amazing but
within his comedy specials he also
contextualizes his artistry he
celebrates other black
intellectuals to elevate the meaning of
his career choices and by doing so he
becomes an intellectual in his own right
dave chappelle is an amazing comedian
because he has some amazing jokes
but it's what he says between those
jokes that makes him legendary
this is not funny at all
i got some [ __ ] jokes too i could do
but i just really just
i released this video on october 27th
which is officially dave chappelle day
in the city of dc where i live
so how does he want us to celebrate in
the future
on dave chappelle day i ask everyone who
wishes to celebrate it
to make one incredible memory for
themself and or somebody else
or maybe do it a different way from now
on on october 27th
everybody in honor of me at duke
ellington
skip school
[Applause]
[Music]
dave chappelle's comedy highlights
countless black artists and he also
frequently highlights
important historical events in the black
community like the crack epidemic the
civil rights movement and the hiv
pandemic
in fact one of chappelle's first
on-screen appearances was to rap about
aids awareness
it hits men and women and the young
ladies
if you want to be like young dave
chappelle and support combating hiv then
a company i recommend for you to check
out is adam and eve
adam and eve is an adult store that
donates 20 of their profits to help
fight the spread of hiv around the world
go to adamandeve.com and use the code c
at checkout to get 50
off one item and free shipping in the us
and canada
they have discrete shipping and 90 day
no hassle returns
a big thanks to adam and eve for
sponsoring this video and a big thanks
to our supporters on patreon who got
early access to this video and have
access to our new podcast
now you hear it in each episode my
co-creator andrew and i break down our
video discuss
related topics and talk about the things
that couldn't fit into a youtube video
you can check out the first episode for
free in the link below and if you like
it head to our patreon to get access to
all the subsequent episodes
including this week's new episode about
dave chappelle thanks for watching